I'd like to begin with an
acknowledgement that we live in a golden
age of the web platform every now and
then there's an article which comes and
does the rounds which states that the
web is dying or already dead and I
really disagree with this CSS grid
flexbox variable fonts service workers
the tools we need to build progressive
web applications we are very powerful
building blocks at our disposal this is
not the sign of a web dying this is the
sign of a web which is very much alive
and thriving we have these web standards
coming in browser at a faster rate than
ever before the process is more
transparent than ever before the gaps
are narrowing we also have access to a
litany of frameworks and libraries and
while there is cause to feel overwhelmed
I know I need to acknowledge that we
have a tremendous amount of choice out
there with which to build our tools and
to get us through that we have at our
disposal a lot of developer tools from
build build build tool chains all the
way to dev tools and browsers and
acknowledging the differences I could
still say that they're tools in all
browsers today provide a robust toolkit
that empower web developers to create
for the web platform web developers what
about web designers my name is Russ
Vaughn and today I want to talk about
dev tools for web designers I'm a
software engineer at Mozilla I work on
Firefox dev tools and previously to this
I worked on a bunch of things at Adobe
like CSS shapes regions masking blend
modes and many other things that never
actually made it and throughout my
career I've always been interested in
the sort of tools we can provide for
these powerful new features now
it's good to begin with a bit of
backstory of how we got to this point
Firebug was a very very popular Firefox
extension which revolutionized the way
we develop it itself was inspired and it
competed with the sort of tools like
Venkman or Dom inspector what set apart
Firebug was a community of enthusiasts
developers from multiple different
companies an ecosystem of extensions and
a driven group of people who wanted to
build better tools right into the
context of the browser so we could get
inspection debugging and many other
things our bug was a pioneer in
developer tools and it is the pioneer
oven which many diff tools are based
today when it comes to web design
features the pioneer I would like to
point out is tablet a CSS playground
built by Lea Veeru and what sets apart
tablet is this very interesting way of
showing property previews on CSS
properties that you can see over here
Lea collected some of the examples
existing at the time and she brought in
some of her own and collected them all
into tablet for us to use it serves as
an inspiration for the dev tools and it
sometimes make me sad that today we have
deft witch Donna do not yet match tablet
in an expressiveness okay but what do
web designers actually need in order to
design in the browser and I think it's
good to make the distinction what I mean
by web designers and that is people who
predominantly use CSS and HTML in their
work not to say that they don't use
JavaScript but their work is primarily
in CSS and HTML well I think there are a
few key principles that dev tools would
need to solve in order for people to
truly design in the browser these are
things like the freeform canvas where
you can explore ideas in an intended
manner with less structure to worry
about the confidence that your changes
will not be lost and you can undo them
web designers also need specialized
tools for the sort of problems they
solve a simple form with input fields is
not enough and they also want to
to be flexible and customizable to fit
the way they work so let's get into it
freedom and buy freedom here I mean
bringing in some of the creative freedom
that people have in tools like Photoshop
or sketch where it's very easy to start
designing something and let your
creativity flow and allow for those
serendipitous moments when you stumble
upon a design you really like that's not
to say that it's impossible to do with
dev tools or to create this in the
browser in code today it's just that
it's a lot less expressive and a lot
less conductive to experimentation to
write code when you want the solution as
opposed to just freeform editing and no
dev tools actually solve this today
because this is a very complex problem
to solve that because well the web is
built over very many years and it has to
be backwards compatible and it has to
lend itself to progressive enhancement
but one tool which comes close to this
is web flow now web flow is a tool an
online editor for creating websites in a
completely manual way just dragging
things around and using specialized
editors this is a video I pulled from
their website which highlights some of
the functionality you have there it's a
lot more expressive and a lot it's a lot
more fast to get to results with web
flow but even it which exports good
quality code from the editor it needs to
fit into their CMS ecosystem and it
needs some form of structure in order to
build these things so you don't have
true for free capabilities to put things
wherever you want you still have some
form of limitations in structure but
it's getting very close so while the
freedom aspect of dev tools isn't solved
in a general sense I do believe that per
component we can still have tools which
give you free form editing capabilities
next up is confidence now pick picture
this you're doing a design in Photoshop
you make some changes you made a mistake
there's no way to go back or you
accidentally refresh the tool
and all of your changes have gone well
sadly that is the situation in many of
the dev tools today the changes are very
ephemeral you come in make some tweaks
you refresh the page they're gone that's
not something you can use as a
professional tool if you don't have
control over these tweaks changes are
happening though there's a new feature
launched recently in Chrome called local
overrides and what local overrides does
is it tracks changes happening in dev
tools writes them to a file and then
reapplies them every time you refresh
the browser so you don't lose changes
anymore
here's a video of it in action and
Chrome so you find it under the sources
panel there's the overrides sub panel
over there first you need to select the
folder where you would save the changes
that the whole file changes once you
allow this you can return to your normal
workflow in dev tools so you can start
making changes to properties and the
browser will start monitoring those
changes and it essentially saves an
entire copy of the file to disk so then
when you refresh even hard refresh like
clearing the cache you always get your
changes back from that file on disk
there's an indicator and next to the
network panel saying hey by the way we
may be overwriting properties as soon as
you disable dev tools you're back to the
normal web site when you re-enable dev
tools local changes are always reapply
so essentially it's taking the local
file and using it instead of whatever is
coming from the server which is great
but there's a caveat if you forget this
thing open you may not know why your dev
changes are not applying on your machine
so there's a caveat there which you need
to be mindful and the indicator next to
the network panel is a hint there an
alternative to local overrides is a
chrome developer tools extension called
fynch developer tools and it does pretty
much the same thing you have to
explicitly enable it there's no folder
to save and then once you enable fynch
you can start making changes to your
styles and dev tools as usual fynch
monitors these changes and it saves them
into memory every time you refresh the
page it goes to memory and bring to
those changes back you have this panel
and dev tools
Finch which shows you a death of
everything you've done you can toggle
the diff on or off to remember what
changes you made and you can also export
these changes and the difference with
Finch is that you can export just the
subset of changes you made instead of
having a huge file saved locally to disk
change is cool next up it's specialized
tool and there's a lot to talk in
specialized tools and by this I mean
editors focused on doing one thing and
doing it very very well and probably the
classic example and specialized tools is
the color picker the color picker in
Chrome I'm probably convinced everyone
has before you start inspecting an
element you find the color value and you
trigger the the color picker over there
and you make changes to the hue see your
changes live in the page this is
powerful because we want contextual
changes but I don't know if you've
noticed recently there is this recent
addition of contrast ratio in the color
picker which when you expand tells you
if the color is you're picking are
actually compliant with accessibility
guidelines which make text easier to
read for people who have a difficulty
reading text of different colors once
you change colors you you actually get a
line over there and it shows you the
threshold above which colors are not
considered compliant with the standards
double A or triple Triple A and I
particularly liked this integration of
accessibility right into the tool when
you're developing as opposed of having
an accessibility step later down the
road it brings the importance of the
field up close and personal
I like this next up the text shadow
editor also in chrome dev tools I don't
know if you've noticed this because it's
very subtle but in the Styles panel of a
chrome dev source there's a hamburger or
a meatball menu and it gives you a
couple more options to add properties
and one of these options is adding the
text shadow now gives this gives you
again a specialized editor which gives
you a lot more flexibility and playing
around with the shadow changing the
direction of it or the spread or the
blur which again lends itself to
creativity to exploration to figuring
out what
works and what doesn't next up the CSS
grid inspector at a preview of this
people love CSS grids because they're an
amazing new layout tool and they need
help designing with grid so CSS grid is
actually being used on the website
conference right now and the grid
inspector gives you a preview of the
grid so you can inspect worried of the
where the elements are actually
positioned on that grid now here's a
more complex example built by my
colleague Jen Simmons where the need for
the grid inspector really comes handy
because you want to know where these
elements are positioned on the grid you
can toggle the display line numbers to
see lines for columns and rows and you
can extend the lines infinitely if that
helps your not and a cool thing is you
can change the color of the grid so
maybe have more contrast if it doesn't
work well with your design and this
setting is maintained after we if we
refresh the page so I know for a fact
that this demo is also responsive and
when you make changes this is where the
inspector comes in very handy because
some elements may have reposition and
then you can see them on the grid
inspector and you can understand what
changed in your layout this is an
invaluable tool if you're learning grid
or if you're playing with grid because
it can get very complex and having the
specialized preview in the grid
inspector is really useful for people
CSS filters in Firefox they have an
editor in Firefox dev tools the really
cool ways of changing the graphic of
something the the styling so over here
we're using the filter editor to add a
hue rotate and we're dragging against
that label over there to pick up colors
for a hero Tate and then we can also add
for example brightness so we can change
we can stack multiple filters together
and what makes this very powerful is
that instead of writing the values
manually you can play around with them
and you don't need to know their limits
their constraints we can also add
saturation to see what the saturation
does and an important thing about
filters is that their order is important
so you can change the order in the
editor and you can live preview that on
the page
to understand the subtle differences
that are actually happening when you're
doing that one thing which is not shown
in the video is that it can also save
these filter presets so you can reapply
them next time you want to edit next up
the CSS gradient editor we have a
gradient editor integrated in the Safari
dev tools wherever you see a linear
radial repeating linear radial gradient
you get a contextual editor to do this
and this is shown on a website called
gradient comm which is a playground for
choosing gradients or creating them
online and getting the for them there
are a lot of great editors out there
people are trying to solve this problem
in many different ways and it's really
good to have a lot of different opinions
one very cool gradient editor that I
found recently is one for easing
gradients built by Andreas Larsen so
Andreas Larsen suggested introducing a
concept of easing to your gradients much
like we have in animation so you don't
have a straight gradient you can have a
curve and he built this specialized
editor to represent what that would mean
it this is a CSS working group proposal
now and you can use the editor to
understand the intent you can change the
angle of the gradient you can change
colors one cool feature which I like a
lot is using steps so you have a stepped
linear gradient over there and I love
this tool so much because it's so
focused on letting you explore different
things
I have literally spent hours playing
with this tool and yes it doesn't solve
all problems for a grid but this is a
prime example of a tool doing one thing
and doing it very well while encouraging
creative exploration I really really
like this alright enough video demos
let's switch to some code this is
something being developed right now in
Firefox nightly and it's called the font
editor so for this I'm going to switch
over and open up the Firefox dev tools
I'm showing this whole presentation in
Firefox nightly by the way and we built
this thing called the font editor which
is an extra panel over here in the
sidebar
that allows you to edit things for fonts
like you can change the size sorry we
need to inspect the element and then we
need to not have our demo crash on stage
bear with me
sorry
that's why it's behind the flag right
now
okay finally got it working so this is
behind the flag in Firefox nightly
because it has bugs it won't have too
many bugs soon enough okay so what we
can do with the font editor we can
inspect an element and then we can
change the size of it we're pretty used
to this or we can make it italic or not
but the font editor is particularly
built for helping you use variable fonts
and variable fonts are very very cool
because they change the way we use fonts
in our website instead of downloading
multiple font files for bold or thin or
italic variable fonts include
information in the font file that allows
the browser to generate bold italic or
any many different things with things
called axes and what the font editor
does it goes and reads the font file and
gives you access to those axes so we're
changing here the weight of our font
over here and you can probably see that
the font weight doesn't go up in
increments of a hundred you can have
much more fine-grained control depending
on the font author we can also change
the width of the font now check out what
happens with the Q over there we can
pick various positions on the axes of
say with overweight that suit our
website we'll and these are called
registered axes which means they're
expected to be there for most variable
fonts they're not compulsory but they're
expected but the very very cool thing
about variable fonts is that you can
build custom axes into the font file as
an author and we can expose those in the
font editor for example over here we can
change the ascender height so the
ascender is basically making our case
our bathes ahrefs a lot of taller or
smaller or we can change the serife
height which is maybe a bit more subtle
to see on stage but it definitely works
in tweaking the font to your desired
behavior what makes this very powerful
is that in order to do these things with
variable fonts you have to read the font
file read the documentation and know
that these custom axes exist I'm going
to turn on a mode called three pane mode
here in Firefox so we can see what's
happening so
the actual notation you need to write by
hand is this thing called in font
variation settings it's a bit it's a bit
cryptic honestly if you want to write
this so the font editor comes really
handy when you want to do these things
and explore and just drive like drive-by
exploration of variable fonts on the web
so we're working on this in Firefox
nightly it's behind the flag thankfully
but the this and variable fonts are
coming very very soon and if you're
interested in variable fonts this is a
website I recommend you go check out
access praxis by Lawrence Penny is a
playground for variable fonts which does
pretty much the same way as our font
editor it gives you the axes so you can
play with them but with the font editor
you can go on any website and have those
axes work for you that was the font
editor next the shape path editor this
is an editor for helping you use CSS
shapes and clip path notation in a very
visual way so over here I'm going to
turn on this demo again and what's
probably very visible is that I have my
text wrapping around the tree over there
and the way it's doing that it's using a
CSS property called shape outside which
is changing the shape of the float
rectangle so we have our text wrapping
around the tree but the notation is
pretty crazy that's a polygon definition
over there which I'm I doubt anyone
would write by hand so for this we have
the CSS shaped path editor we can enable
it by clicking over here and then we get
an overlay of an editor so we can drag
these points around thank you so we can
drag these points around we could double
click to remove them and we can see our
changes happening contextually on the
page and this is important because stuff
in HTML interacts you need to do this on
the page so you can understand what's
going on now here's a trick we can hold
down the ctrl key on Windows or the
command key and press this thing and now
we get a transforms editor which allows
us to change the entire shape up and
down we can also rotate the shape we can
scale it many crazy different things
this is working for shape outside
properties
now but it also works for clip paths
because they use the same value notation
and what's an alice in wonderland' them
or without the Cheshire cat
well the Cheshire cat has always been
watching us from up here I can reveal it
by inspecting this element which has a
clip path of circle and it's very small
but as I drag this handle over here I
can reveal we were actually clipping an
element thank you we're actually
clipping this element with a clip path
and again the notation for circle is
relatively easy but you can imagine this
being very handy for polygons which it
also works for an extra thing you see
over there is the rectangle that is
informing you of the extent of the
element which would be clipped so you
understand if say for example you don't
see why clipping doesn't happen outside
of it that's your representation so
these are tools that we're building to
empower you to play with features right
into the browser specialized tools now
CSS shapes is I think it's done in
Firefox and it's a minute like the
release is a minute next couple of weeks
I believe so
shapes are coming in Firefox and the
shape editor launching at the same time
let's switch over to the last part which
is ergonomic and this means that people
really love tools when they can
customize them to suit the way they work
people work in many different ways
throughout our our industry and that's
probably not news to you but with maybe
is news is that the developer tools team
in any browser you know has very few
people working on it and there's
generally very few people maintaining
code base for a large large audience
some of us are very thankful to have
contributors like volunteers we have at
Mozilla who fix bugs and who even
implement features altogether and we're
really thankful for their effort but the
reality is we all need to work against
some priorities and sometimes those
priorities may not be the same thing you
care about and when people want
something built they just go ahead and
do it
so I was really happy to learn
earlier this month that reacted EV tools
a chrome dev tools extension now has
over 1 million users as much as we love
react in dev tools I think it's hard to
imagine that anyone would prioritize
building dev tools in 4 react into dev
tools knowing how transient and how
ever-changing frameworks are but that
didn't stop people who were motivated
and skilled enough to build these tools
and share them with others they
recognized the need and they built a
tool for it and it's popular and this is
the power of building extensions so at
this point I should just encourage all
of you to go build dev tools extensions
for web designers well I could do that
well you can get a panel added to your
dev tools like my extension over there
or you can get a sidebar panel place
next to the rules over there or if
you're using three pane mode in Firefox
you can have the rules panel separate
and you have a design surface next to it
so you can maybe make changes and see
those changes happening in the rule view
but if that panel looks very lonely and
empty it's because it is in reality dev
tools extensions are very very isolated
they know almost nothing about the dev
tools environment and they have a very
loose connection with the inspected page
through a rudimentary text-based
protocol so if you want to build dev
tools for designers you don't actually
have access to the rule view you don't
know which rules have applied to that
element you don't know if the node is
changing if the media queries have
changed you don't know if the dev tools
has closed underneath your feet that's
kind of weird so if you want to build
dev tools extensions right now you have
to do a lot of work just to get to the
point where you can start building your
specialized editor now that's not a good
way of working so here comes a proposal
what if we could change that what if we
can write extension api's that allow you
to plug into the rule view and subscribe
with a specialized editor for property
say you just want to write an editor for
font-weight which has a slider with
notches over there and maybe a drop down
to pick one of the instances and
really interested just in font wait you
should be able to give the browser this
extension and let the browser show it
next to the properties which matter the
browser should do the legwork of finding
the rules showing your editor closing
your editor sending events and if the
note has changed and sending events and
if the property was overwritten by
something else but there's no real
reason why we should only expose this to
one editor at a time we could have
multiple editors per property multiple
color Pickers per property the example I
showed earlier from andreas Larsen's
gradient editor it does one thing very
very well it doesn't need to do
everything once you have a canvas where
you can actually have multiple people
designing different editors for
different functionality and there's also
no need to have only one editor open at
the same time you can have multiple
editors each one of them specialized and
use these in tandem to get the results
that you actually want so we can have a
font size editor which allows you to see
if what you're picking is not legible or
not or margin which does shorthand
expansion over there
these are would be inline editors and
I'll give you the freedom to really
focus on something you want to implement
a specialized editor where we can also
open up the previews so we can have
previews of angles and this is a demo
built by one of my colleagues Nicolas we
can get closer to that vision Leah had
with tablet and expose the preview
functionality as tooltips for people
just to implement one preview at a time
and if we have an extension ecosystem
and the browser knows these extensions
exist in the store then it could get to
a point where we could smartly look at
something see a property that there's an
editor for and we can recommend this to
you in context so you can install an
extension for dev tools right in context
and solve the problem as you are there
now if these things sound interesting to
you and if you want to build extensions
like these if you're a web designer who
wants extensions built for them like
this
we are very very interested in hearing
from you so please reach out to either
me or any of my colleagues and Firefox
dev tools we really want to understand
what classes of problems you're trying
to solve so as to build an API which
really serves your needs well because
we're really interested in building
tools that work well for you because
until we do that we are always going to
do some form of limitation and the
creative expression you get into dev
tools and we cannot really design in the
browser unless we make dev tools for
designers actually good thank you very
much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]